[MUSIC PLAYING]
GARY GENSLER: We
can use technology
to make finance more
inclusive and more
accessible to many more millions
of people in our country
and many more
hundreds of millions
of people around the globe.
SARAH HANSEN: Today on
Chalk Radio, modern money.
In this episode, we're taking
a look at 15.S08 FinTech:
Shaping the Financial World.
This is a course,
about money and how
it works in a constantly
changing digital environment.
GARY GENSLER: My
research and teaching
is all about the intersection
between finance and technology.
And what better place
to do it but at MIT?
SARAH HANSEN: Our guest today
is Professor Gary Gensler.
He co-directs MIT's
FinTech@CSAIL,
which stands for Computer
Science and AI Lab.
Professor Gensler has
a unique perspective
in that he's teaching a subject
that's continuously evolving.
So how does an educator
teach something that
changes so much and so rapidly?
How do you prepare
students to work
in a new and, oftentimes,
vastly different
context, one that literally
might not even exist yet?
But before we dive
into all of that,
we first have to
understand, what is FinTech?
GARY GENSLER: This
term, FinTech,
which came about in the
last 20 or so years,
can mean different things
to different folks.
For me, I think of it as
how is finance changing
due to new technologies?
And the original
FinTech was money
itself invented thousands
of years ago by humans.
But usually, a lot
of folks these days
will call FinTech
the companies that
are disrupting the world
of finance using machine
learning or using something
called blockchain technology.
But 20 years ago, it
would be correct to say
that what technology was
disrupting finance more
than anything else
was the internet.
And 10 or 15 years
ago, the technology
that was disrupting
finance the most
was mobile phones and cloud.
And so I teach it
from a broader view
and try to prepare
students with this concept,
so they're ready for
the 2030s and the 2040s.
What technologies then will be
highly disruptive in finance?
It's really about how
technology is changing
the world of finance
and has for centuries
and will for centuries to come.
And right now,
we're living through
this transitional period
of machine learning,
artificial intelligence,
Internet of Things,
blockchain technology.
In a decade from now, it will
be some other transition.
And so I really try
to engage the students
on what that means, what those
big technology movements mean
as they come into
the technology stack,
and then they just
become accepted.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARAH HANSEN: In helping
me understand what FinTech
actually is, Professor Gensler
made some really interesting
observations about the
way we use money now
versus even just 10 years
ago and what that implies
about where we're headed.
GARY GENSLER: That
which we call money,
that which Plato and
Aristotle called money,
was just society's
representation of something
of value.
But boy, in the 21st
century, aren't we there--
that you can just wave
your mobile phone,
and you move value--
what we call money.
The greatest changes
of the early 2020s
is about two forms of
artificial intelligence.
One is machine learning.
Machine learning has
a remarkable ability
to extract correlations
in data where
we couldn't find it earlier
with earlier forms of math--
linear algebra and so forth.
And the second form of
artificial intelligence
that's dramatically
changing finance
is natural language processing.
What do these words mean?
They're just kind of
fancy words to say,
can you move human language
to computer language?
And guess what?
All day long, that's
happening, and we're
starting to get robo advice.
And robo advisory platforms
can deliver finance far more
broadly to far more people.
So Bank of America has its
voice assistant, Erica.
But millions of their
customers are now using Erica--
[LAUGHS]---- to do
modest transactions--
move bank balances
around, things like that.
So we try, in the classroom, to
think about this with students
and sort of prepare them.
What are the next technologies?
Not just the technologies
like machine learning
and natural language
processing, but what
are the next technologies?
And how do we think of
entrepreneurial strategy--
how to think of the strategy to
use new technologies to provide
services.
And then the classic
way that you always
have to think about
as an entrepreneur--
how can you do something better,
quicker, cheaper that's not
been done today?
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARAH HANSEN: During
my conversation
with Professor Gensler,
I began to realize
how far-reaching the
implications of FinTech can be.
Expanding access to
financial literacy
is a really important outcome
that drives his teaching
and his passion for the work.
GARY GENSLER: What
I was drawn to MIT
about was this sense that maybe
we could democratize capitalism
a bit more, that we
can use technology
to make finance more
inclusive and more
accessible to many more millions
of people in our country
and many more
hundreds of millions
of people around the globe.
New technologies come
along every decade or so,
and then they disrupt
the status quo.
And what's really
exciting is, at MIT,
we're at the forefront of
those new technologies.
And we can bring those
practices, those new practices,
into the classroom
and say, well, now
what's this doing to finance?
What does it mean that a big
technology company is starting
to have a credit card, maybe?
What does it mean that Apple
credit card exists, or Facebook
wants to have a worldwide
currency called Libra
or that we might
provide insurance that's
going to be
measuring our Fitbits
or watches or our mobile devices
as to whether we're healthy
or not?
SARAH HANSEN: Students from
all areas of MIT's Sloan School
of Management, and even
students registered
from other schools, flock
to Professor Gensler's class
to learn more about what the
future of finance looks like
and how they might
help shape it.
GARY GENSLER: Students
come into this class
for multiple purposes.
But I'd say the majority
are really interested how
these new technologies
might be disrupting
a big part of an economy.
And the students are
from all over the globe.
And dominantly,
they're thinking about,
I want to understand
how this technology is
disrupting finance.
So I asked all the students to
write a memo, a clearly worded
recommendation memo.
But their recommendation-- they
can pick one of three CEOs--
Jeff Bezos of Amazon;
Brian Moynihan,
who runs Bank of America;
or Mark Andreessen,
who runs a big venture capital
firm, Andreessen Horowitz.
And I said, you pick
whether you want
to write about the
provision of credit,
the provision of credit cards,
the provision of automobile
insurance, the
provision of mortgages.
You pick whatever you
want to pick in finance,
but you have to write
a CEO recommendation
memo with a clearly stated
recommendation to Amazon,
Bank of America, or
Andreessen Horowitz.
And a little over half the
students picked Amazon.
They were all really
interesting memos to read.
And the students engage.
They engage because
there's tremendous benefit
to giving students a real
live thing to address.
It's a real live thing
where I say, listen,
if this is a great memo,
I'll figure out the way
to get it to Jeff Bezos.
I'll figure out the way to
get it to Brian Moynihan.
And the students believe
me because I could get
a really great memo to them.
Some students will say, can I
write it to somebody in Brazil
instead?
And I always say yes.
Had a great memo to the CEO
of Tencent, the big technology
network in China.
And it was one of the best
memos this group of students
put together.
I would say to other
educators, trust the students.
If you give them a little bit of
an open-ended prompt like this,
a big majority will
rise to the occasion.
SARAH HANSEN: As is the case
with most things nowadays,
Professor Gensler's course is
formatted a little differently
in the time of COVID-19.
But he's seen some
pretty remarkable results
at achieving some
semblance of normalcy
in his new class format.
GARY GENSLER: We're in
very unusual times--
that those of us who
learned our teaching
skills in the
classroom with anywhere
from 15 to 100
students in the class,
that you are all having
a shared experience.
All of a sudden, with a snap
of a finger, we're online.
Most of us at Sloan felt it
was really important to keep
some sense of community.
And so when I started
the first class online,
I asked all the students--
those that could-- to listen
together synchronously.
And so this class was
taught at 8:30 to 10:00 AM
on Monday and Wednesday.
And so for many time
zones, it worked.
But did it really work
for somebody sitting
in Europe who had flown back?
So we did record it, but
we got about 85% to 90%
of the students tying
in synchronously.
And I felt it was
not only important
that it was synchronous,
but secondly, that everyone
had their video on.
And I would tell the students--
I said, I know
that you might have
a friend, a spouse, a lover, a
child walk through the camera.
You might have a
delivery, which--
One day, I was teaching,
and I had a delivery.
And there was a
pounding on the door.
And I had to say to the
students, excuse me.
I have to go to the door.
But I said, that's life.
We're going to relax
about all of this.
But I felt it formed a
better sense of community.
SARAH HANSEN: Before
teaching at MIT,
Professor Gensler cut his
teeth in the professional
and political world
working for Goldman Sachs;
the US Department of Treasury;
Hillary Clinton's campaign;
Paul Sarbanes in the US
Senate, and with Barack Obama's
administration, chairing
something called the Commodity
Futures Trading Commission.
His understanding of what makes
a successful, well-equipped
professional shines
through in his classes.
Gensler isn't just
developing domain knowledge
but cultivating humans
and professionals.
I want to read something
to you that you've written.
GARY GENSLER: Oh my God.
This is the embarrassing moment.
SARAH HANSEN: [LAUGHS]
No, it's good.
It says "respect and courtesy
build reputations, networks,
and trust."
That seems important
in your teaching.
So I'm wondering how your
focus on helping students
cultivate professionalism kind
of plays out in the course.
How do you teach that?
GARY GENSLER: So
I think that each
of us that walk into a classroom
have a big responsibility.
It's such a privilege
to be at MIT
with this incredible student
body and faculty and staff.
But I feel that we have this
responsibility that goes
beyond our domain knowledge.
Of course, I'm in the classroom
teaching finance and technology
and this intersection of how
machine learning and blockchain
technology and
Internet of Things
is changing the
world of finance.
But I also think
that when I look back
at the faculty members I learned
the most from when I went--
I went to Wharton--
it was not about
the domain knowledge
of accounting or finance or
linear algebra or biology.
It was more about values.
It was more about
professionalism.
And I've been honored to
work at very high levels
of professionalism.
Often, the race
goes to the person
who's prepped the most,
who's been courteous, who
listens as much as they
talk, who asks questions
that are relevant.
And I come back to that,
not just in the classroom,
but I offer lunches
to the students.
They sign up in an
open signup forum
where up to eight
students can sign up.
And I usually do this in person.
But what I found
in this COVID time,
there was such a demand that
I set up lunches twice a week
all through the six weeks.
And they were nearly always
booked with eight students.
And we would just
have no agenda other
than we would talk about
careers and professionalism
and the like.
So maybe for some small
percentage of the students,
it will stick.
And then I usually
end my last lecture
in every one of my
classes, and I do a quote
from Benjamin Franklin.
And Benjamin Franklin, believe
it or not, spoke about money.
So I figure I get a
little bit of a pass
if I get hokey on the last day.
And I bring Benjamin Franklin
and this wonderful, warm quote
that you can look up about
Benjamin Franklin and money.
But what he really is talking
about is paying it forward.
He talks about if you should--
somebody does you a favor.
The way that you repay the favor
is doing the favor to others.
And he says this is the best
form of money he knows--
to redo a favor by
paying it back to others.
I feel that those of
us who are privileged
to be in these positions,
if we can share that,
and it sticks with
some percentage
of the students, that's
as important-- maybe
more important-- than the
domain knowledge and the domain
analysis.
I mean, I like to think we
teach a lot more than knowledge,
that we teach a way of thinking.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
SARAH HANSEN: If you're ready
to learn more about FinTech,
you can visit Professor
Gensler's course materials
on our MIT
OpenCourseWare website.
And if you're an
educator who reuses
the materials in
your own teaching,
call or write to us
to share your story.
You'll help inspire others.
Thank you so much for listening.
And if you like what
you've heard so far, please
consider leaving us a review
wherever you're listening
to this podcast today.
Signing off from
Cambridge, Massachusetts,
I'm Sarah Hansen from
MIT OpenCourseWare.
CHILD: Ma, pahk the cah!